thousands converged on the central
israeli town of modi
the focal point of a nationwide
outpouring of mourning
a burial service for the three murdered
teenagers
the people of israel have suffered a
great trauma since thursday of two weeks
ago we have been living as if we are in
a movie but it has a terrible ending
i no longer have a brother
but beyond the grieving everyone is also
wondering what israel will do next
the security cabinet was scheduled to
meet after the burial to formulate a
response
some want to see a massive strike in
gaza or the west bank but others favor a
more restrained reaction
one way or the other israel has placed
the blame with radical hamas islamists
we've exposed the two main suspects who
we believe are involved in this act
action they are both hamas operatives
they have both served time for carrying
out acts of violent terrorism this is
the reality we are facing these people
they have a culture of kidnapping
israeli security officials suspected
hamas soon after the three boys went
missing
and once their bodies were discovered
near hebron the army stepped up military
operations in the west bank
the homes of the two main suspects are
largely destroyed
then the israeli air force pounded gaza
with airstrikes
palestinians in the west bank had their
own mourning to do a young man was shot
by israeli forces in a raid at the
janine refugee camp
concern is mounting that this could mark
the beginning of another bloody chapter
in the conflict between israel and the
palestinians
you